speaking of joe rogan
i think that jamie his producer is uh
immune to uh uh psychedelic so maybe
he's he's a good recruit for the state
to test so that's interesting now i'm
not
the caveat i'm not encouraging anything
illicit but just
theoretically my first question as a far
behavioral pharmacologist is like you
know increase the dose
chris you know like really nobody i'm
not telling him jamie to do that but
like
okay like you know you're taking the
same amount that friends might be taking
but
yeah but he was also referring to the
psychedelic effects
of edible marijuana which is is there
is there uh rules on uh
dosage for um uh like marijuana
is there limits like what places where
it's this is this all goes
it probably is state by state right it
is but most they've gone that direction
and states that didn't initially have
these rules have no
now have them so it was like you'll get
i think you know five
ten mil i think ten five or ten
milligrams of thc
yeah being a common and and like and
this is an important thing like where
they've moved from not being allowed to
say
like have a whole candy bar and have
each of the eight or ten squares on the
counter bar being 10
milligrams but it's like no the whole
thing because like you know someone gets
a candy bar they they're eating the
freaking candy bar
yeah and it's like if you unless you're
a daily cannabis user
if you if you take you know 100
milligrams it's like
that's what could lead to a bad trip
yeah for someone and it's like you know
a lot of these people it's like oh you
used to smoke a little weed in college
they might say
they're visiting denver for a business
trip and like why not let's give it a
shot
you know and they're like oh i don't
want to smoke something because it's
going to so i'm going to be safer with
this edible
consume this massive you know but
there's huge tolerance so a regular like
for
someone who's smoking weed every day
they might take five milligrams and
kind of hardly feel anything and they
might not they may really need
something like 30 40 50 milligrams to
have a strong effect
but yeah so that's they've evolved in
terms of the rules about like okay
what constitutes a dose you know
which is why you see less big candy bars
and more or if you're is you're
if it is a whole candy bar you're only
getting a smaller dose like 10
milligrams or
yeah because that is where people get in
trouble more often with edibles
yeah uh except joey diaz which i've
heard
that's definitely something i want to
talk to out of the crazy comedians i
want to talk
you